to be with a man that is has a previous
children from a previous relationship
I'm not going to say oh he needs to be
right he used to have eight figures he
needs to be single he can't have kids
I'm not doing that I know that okay I've
got a child my bargaining power is less
than right but the thing is it would be
it would be a good deal for you because
when a guy has kids it's a sign of
pre-selection that he can take care of
them so that's that's the thing that
like I see in churches is they tell men
to accept bad deals because it would be
a good deal for you would be a bad deal
for him what if he has kids yeah even so
but he can take care of those kids I'm
taking care of mine right right but like
men don't care about your money like our
bargaining power is different it's
Purity and youth where you get
protection and provisioning so you get
you get the benefits and he doesn't but
if you have the trump card of um being
cooperative being submissive that can
work out I'm saying it's a good
character you're you're correct and it
can but what I'm saying is one there
aren't enough men in the church to even
for everyone to get married and the
other issue is that you're again you're
selling a used car for new prices when
if you you know when really you're on
sale but you should be and you might
have bet like and I would think people
in the church like a lot of like the
single mothers I see in the church would
have better outcomes if they just put
themselves on sale because they also say
to be submissive yeah and and being
submissive isn't oh you have to wait to
marry me to have sex but like because
that's on your rules
the discounts
though yes trust me stop it
it I still are also the ones that are
actually on it like in their face
they're not having sex either so I've
been quoted by a man in church and he
didn't attempt to have sex with me
because he understood that and he was
single he didn't have a child you're
more likely to meet a man yeah
he was willing to do the journey with me
because he took his faith seriously why
didn't you marry him because he wasn't
the right one for me no because you
weren't attracted to him because he was
a Sim no we no
because because that's that that synth
Behavior that's it like honestly because
if you if you had a son that was
childless you wouldn't want him to date
a single mother that's a born-again
virgin and you might not say born again
virgin but you may as well be yeah but
can I just say I actually know and a
couple who met in church I'm going to
give you some hope here and they both
had children and they have both they
married and they are having they're
expecting that but possibility of
possibility possibility or women women
like thinking possibilities instead of
probabilities when the majority of the
women I see in the church are single so
you can say oh here's this fairy tale
that might happen to you to you but if
you keep selling a used car at new
prices that like the majority of women
will end up single and that's what
you're seeing in the churches walk into
any church the majority of the women are
single they think I've got Jesus so I'm
okay
and they think that but the problem is a
lot of women will be homeless even in
the UK you guys have a lot of bailout
programs but let's say let's say they
can't afford those anymore where will
you go do you have 2.5 million for
retirement you'll be on the streets and
so finding a relationship can be life or
death for a lot of women because he's
more vulnerable than women on the tree
so you can like you can say oh it's nice
and like like here here's this fairy
tale that could happen for you and I
think it's because like you're very
sweet but the probability is a lot
longer yeah can I can I also say that
there's a lot of working parts to
um being a single Christian woman
because one of the reasons as well if
especially for those of you that are not
spiritual I dreamed that this man was
not the man for me I asked God is this
the man and eventually after a couple of
weeks of dating the guy God spoke to me
a dream said he's not the guy yeah so at
the end of the day for me whoever I
marry now there's no divorce we are
dying together so I want to do it the
right way okay at the same time a lot of
women do I agree with you they do use
Jesus as a crutch without doing the
inner self work it's you you will stay
single if you do not do the you know I
just think to a guy that sounds like
nonsense but like this sound this sounds
like because it's out because because it
sounds like nonsense to me but I'm not
spiritual there's things that you if
you're not using your spiritual eyes to
see certain things no no no don't don't
do that don't do that I spent I spent 12
years in Catholic school I grew up in a
Catholic face I I actually wanted to be
a virgin until I was married and I and I
waited a long time and and like didn't
get they didn't do any of that so you
can't say oh it's like a spiritual thing
you don't feel spiritually but I'm
saying I'm saying you can say like inner
work like whatever but like I'm talking
about results but I'm talking about a
spirit-led life not going to church
church going to church you're not being
mocked on your attendance your God
weighs your heart so you could be going
to church there's people that never miss
a Sunday but their heart is black and I
I understand I understand that like but
what I'm saying is like the world
doesn't owe you understanding that's
fine and that's fine but I'm saying like
if if you don't have 2.5 million to
retire there's a chance you could be
homeless if you don't figure out how to
get along with a dude and it's going to
be hard to do that if you're selling a
used car for new prices fair enough but
I'm also so in business myself I'm I
provide for myself I'm not um quick
question please what was the reason for
single ladies being in church what was
is there does anyone know the main
reason I mean I I I think that like the
church has driven out men because one
they tell them to accept bad deals too
they thought they'd go to church and
find a wife and they find the girls are
freakier in the church than out of the
church
and three like feminism has infiltrated
a lot of and and feminine and guys guys
one at a time and feminism has
infiltrated a lot of the churches and so
it's like they don't really stand for
anything anymore I see I see that I mean
I don't know if this drives out men in
particular but I see I see gay flags
outside of churches not my church
okay so what on the other side what do
you think are the reasons why we don't
have men in church I think I think I
think the church has driven out men
because feminism has infiltrated the
church agreed and so I think they've
taken power away from Men in the church
and they've given it to the women yes we
call that the Jezebel spirit the church
has basically abandoned all of the
narratives that attracted men to it in
the first place you know they don't they
don't emphasize the need to take
responsibility into the you know the
bear your cross narrative that they used
to and I I was raised atheist
um I would now describe myself as
religiously confused
but I I recently attended church a few
months ago thinking you know this is
something I'm interested in I've been
developing a sort of spiritual practice
and I went there looking for that
narrative you know in in the style of
Jordan Peterson who who picks apart the
biblical stories and explains what they
mean the significance they have to you
as a person and how you can improve
yourself as a person using the biblical
stories and I went there and I found it
really wishy-washy and uninteresting
and slightly woke as well
um you know like in the middle of the
sermon the Reverend started going on
some tangent about Asylum Seekers and
refugees the need to welcome them all in
and things like that and although I
think that's a separate conversation to
the church and that's not what the the
whole point of the religious Endeavor is
it is supposed to be about introspection
and making yourself a better person not
about this social justice thing that
they seem to have picked up and so I
think that's why a lot of men are
leaving the church or even even like Roe
versus Wade in the US that should be a
win for churches it is like that yeah it
should be but it's not like even even
the church I was involved in in the US
they can't come forward and say that's a
win
exactly so secularism has infiltrated
the church yeah there's not that I agree
I think um
Jesus that guy on the cross like this
yeah kinky you know he's been a
feminized they've feminized God and at
the end of the day I agree with what you
said if you actually look at the
accounts of the Bible men were men women
women were led by men there was of men
had Authority and I think you are
absolutely right feminism has
infiltrated the church and that male
Authority is not encouraged or
celebrated even in society as a whole
masculinity is frowned upon you're
called toxic quickly nowadays A man
can't even say oh hey babes you look
good can I get a number because even on
the train now like don't get me wrong
some things aren't necessary like
touching without consent is
inappropriate but generally a man is not
encouraged to be an alpha male or I know
that word's thrown around but I mean
someone that is aggressive not in a
negative way but you know actively
masculine that is frowned upon yeah well
and I also think
I think they encouraged Behavior they
tell you to wait for a born-again virgin
and they I don't know why they would
tell girls to wait but the man also is
told to wait as well yeah but you know
it's different it's like a bad deal for
him because he still has to protect and
provide but he doesn't get Purity or
youths so yeah so before she went to the
church it's like it's like okay
but it's not but men and women okay okay
I'll give you an example but men and
women aren't the same so I went to
Carnival and I interviewed men yeah I
said what would you rather pick would
you rather have a girl that had fifty
thousand dollars worth of credit card
debt you have to pay off or 50 bodies
and I asked the same question to men and
to women and the women said you know I
can deal with the bodies I'm not taking
the debt and the guy said I will pay off
fifty thousand dollars in debt before I
had before I take a girl with 50 bodies
and and so it's like men and women don't
value Purity at the same rate meant that
that's like one of the most important
things to them they don't want to be
with a girl that has done embarrassing
in the past that's embarrassing to
them where women don't we don't really
care it's kind of a flat it's the um the
body counter the debt as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible